Florida Governor Rick Scott is among a
growing chorus of those calling for FBI
director Christopher ray to resign
following a bombshell revelation we
learned today that a caller tipped the
bureau off just last month about the
Florida school shooting suspect Nicholas
Cruz they were told he wanted to kill
people and was a potential school
shooter so how could the FBI watch this
so badly joining us now to explain how
these tips fell through the cracks is
Steve Rogers a former member of the FBI
joint terror Steve this is just the
heartbreaker in so many ways I try to
put myself in the position of a parent
or a spouse of one of the teachers of
coaches who died in this horrific attack
the FBI gets this YouTube tip in
September and they some reason can't
figure out who posted that comment about
I'm going to be a professional school
shooter then in January a tipster calls
in and it's very specific a person close
to Cruz that he has a gun etc etc he's
gonna he could shoot a school and then
nothing what happened Laura this was an
epic failure of leadership at FBI
headquarters an epic failure of
information sharing and I'm sure you
remember as I do on President Trump in
the early days of this campaign wonders
about problems in our intelligence
agencies the president was right but
little did we know that it went way up
to FBI headquarters there's a process
that we go through in police work when
you get tips like that and I've got to
tell you the magnitude the most profound
tip they got was what was on that
YouTube about being a professional
shooter you could you connect the dots
you don't stop the investigation when I
heard that FBI agent talked about well
we've you know we looked at the youtubes
we couldn't find the IP address exactly
I said I was stunned I've been in law
enforcement 38 years and my instinct
would tell me there is something wrong
here and you know you do it would be
simple why not just put the guy's name
in the Instagram platform or Facebook
platform it what's his name
and look what came up and then they
would have had the name they could have
got the local police and I and the
question I have is that I I believe
still has to be looked into did the
local police give the FBI any
information at all regarding the
domestic violence calls regarding they
normally wouldn't because they're not
federal issues but but when that name
came up I'm just wondering all the
information the police had about this
guy and on domestic violence calls I'll
show you know this one police respond to
a house on any type of violence or
mentally ill person way enroute we ask
the question are there any weapons in
the house because usually every Police
Department has a databank
as to every home that has a weapon to
protect officers where where on earth
was the breakdown there so there was
little or no information sharing and
that's what has to be investigated
see if they visited his house 39 times
for a variety of things his mother was
clearly afraid of him he was cutting
himself on you on on Instagram after his
girlfriend broke up with him I mean I
guess he was a decent employee at the
Dollar General Store but other than that
he was a total nutjob and it seemed to
me that along the way it was red flag
after red flag after red flag but it's
almost like people are are worried about
offending someone or abridging abridging
someone's privacy and and and I don't
know if it's just like they're
overloaded or there's inertia or it's
bureaucracy but man this was a colossal
mistake I think it was a colossal
mistake on the local level on the state
level and on the federal level but the
federal level I think really takes the
cake
for me with the January 5th oh you're
right there's there's no excuse for what
happened there and and and and and I'll
share with you this look cops get
instinct you get instinct and and I've
asked all week any FBI agent who knows
anything about how this happened and
where the failures were Laura they need
to come forward you know you know cops
put up this blue wall of silence and and
it happens on a local level it happens
on a federal level break down tear down
that blue wall of silence for the good
of this country because a lot of cops
know a lot of things and they won't come
forward for one reason or another but in
this case they've got to come forward
and it's also amazing that in that
YouTube visit that the FBI field office
and Mississippi made to the the man who
complained who raised an alarm about it
they visited him twice they had the name
Nicholas Cruz from the posting why
wasn't that part of an FBI file system
so when this January 5th call came in
about Nicholas Cruz they're like whoa
okay now it it seems like there should
be like a cross-referencing program I
know maybe that's silly what I'm saying
no it is not silly and then obvious
that was my point earlier did local
police did the school system share
information and when this particular
name came up I'm sure the local police
saw that YouTube I mean I mean everybody
seemed to have known about it when that
name came up
did anybody think you know maybe we
should check with federal authorities or
maybe federal authorities should check
with the locals if they found out where
this address was epic failure and
leadership epic failure in information
sharing should the FBI director resign I
said earlier and I'll say it again that
the entire leadership at FBI
headquarters should resign or be fired
we were warned by the president United
States Donald Trump early on in this and
I'm glad that he now has the Attorney
General Sessions looking into this
investigating it and I believe we're
gonna see people leaving that
headquarters building we've got 17
people dead I appreciate it very much
thank you so much